i'll take five six and under
so how long were you dating your
previous girlfriend i don't want to like
say her name i don't want to air her out
or anything like that doesn't
but you go on my channel every time i
put her all over your channel
she's all over my channel she she texted
me today when i released the video today
because i made some crack about how it's
not my
fault that she's there's an issue
between the two of them were you guys
dating
i don't know like about 14 15 months and
then why did why did you guys end up
breaking up
i thought look listen any relationship
there's like ebbs and flows right like
sometimes it's amazing and then
sometimes you know
it's it's good but it's not as good as
it was at one time like there's obvious
right like
not bad but sometimes you're more over
the top in love than others
so we would have a couple of great weeks
and then we'd have a week where we
didn't talk or even see each other for a
week
what's going on just reading okay
nothing keep going so
so there would be times when we were
texting you know whatever five ten times
a day as opposed to
she's texting me 30 times a day and
calling me and saying
i can't wait to see you and you know i
love you so much and you know that so
those things are going back and forth
but it's a good relationship in my
opinion
listen one day what first of all
this kills me she wants to move in
like we're dating there was a an issue
with this chick she was dating right so
she was dating this chick when we met
and then she broke up with her to be
with me and then the girl came back
around and she's like look i'm gonna
just be with her and i'm sorry and i'm
like you're messing up but whatever she
was
bisexual right and then she comes back
again like a week later she's like i
messed up i screwed up forget her
i'm sorry i'm in love with you and then
so that went on for a few months
eventually she comes back and i'm like
look we're done i mean you know this
i'm tired of this she's like no you
don't understand i'm all in i want to
move in together i'm in love with you
it's i messed up i screwed up great
so a few months later we tell our pos
that we're seeing each other
okay because we're both on probation we
have to get permission so we get our
get permission then i say i'm going to
go run on i'm we're going to run an
apartment
she's then she starts backpedaling
well i'm about to go to start school
full-time and i don't know
and what about my half of the rent and
this and that and
give it let's give it another month and
okay another month goes by and then
another month goes by
and then i said look i i i got to move
out of i'm living in someone's spare
room i gotta get out of here
you know so i'm gonna run an apartment
you're moving in with me she's like i
can't afford my half of the rent i just
started school
i'm like i'll pay your half of the rent
and she's like
well the problem is my dad i live with
my dad i'm so close and my car's a piece
of junk and your car is a piece of junk
we'll get you a new car
i'll i'll i'll help you with the car
payment then it comes back it's like
no i can't afford that i'll pay the car
payment
now what i just need more time i need
more time
her into a corner oh yeah of course what
am i gonna look look it's
put up a shut up if i'm in i'm 100 i'm
all in
i mean i've said this before if i'm
going in the bank i'm not slipping the
[ __ ] teller some [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
note
and walking out with three thousand
dollars i'm going into the vault with an
ak-47
i'm zip tying everybody and i'm leaving
with the contents
you're either in or you're out so she's
not all in
that's is that wrong no i love it so i'm
saying you're not all in
then something's wrong i get an
apartment she's coming over back and
forth back and forth
and then anyway one day she comes over
and she's
basically comes over and we end up going
we end up going to
uh to dinner first i remember she said
she wanted to go to dinner
red lobster applebee's lobsters
no where did we go i don't know like
some buffalo wing house or something
buffalo wild wings wild one yeah
hell yeah that place has more tv screens
than anywhere
it does have a lot there's a lot of
sports on i feel like i'm just getting i
feel like i'm getting sunburned my
skin's just getting
fried from all the tv all the [ __ ]
screens everywhere
anyways you guys go to bdubs then what
happens
i don't like that he calls it b-dubs so
that's what people call do they
it's by my house bro
anyway we go there and uh austin what do
you call it
well it's not my kind of place okay it's
a sports bar i'd rather not go there
whatever not my call so we go in
we sit down and i said
so what do you want to talk about i'm
happy i'm having a good time my
girlfriend's here
we just had sex everything's good that's
about to change
yeah we just everything's good like we
just i knocked one out we're gonna go
eat
going back life's good life's good sure
enough we sit down and i said you want
to talk and she goes
she and i said uh what did you want to
talk about and she goes maybe we
shouldn't talk here
and i went when i got to throw a fit i
said
what are you breaking up with me and she
goes yeah and i went
what we just ordered and i was like oh
no oh look i went what and she goes
i just it's just not working and i just
don't feel like we're gonna this is
gonna last and i then i went oh i said
hold on hey hey
to the secretary to the not secretary to
the waitress like i said can you back
box all that stuff up and get me the tab
as soon as humanly possible
and she goes is everything okay so yeah
we're just wrapping this up real quick
this is over
so i need that stuff so i can get going
as quickly as possible i appreciate it
and she went she got the stuff and came
back and jess is just sitting there
staring at me she's like
do you want what do you want to talk
about i said there's another what's
there to talk about you don't want to be
with me
i've been through this before we've been
through this this is a re
we had a good year since the last one
but this is it
so sure enough we get our stuff we go
back we walk into the house
she's sitting there she's like do you
want to talk about this what's there to
talk about
do you have any of your stuff that you
need to get it's over
if it's over it's over and you know i
was furious
so then she left and then a couple days
later i started getting the text
from her are you okay i know you're
upset my dad said that i probably
shouldn't call you and i said yeah
you're right you shouldn't call me
there's
no reason to text and we're done a
couple more days
and then you know she starts posting
stuff on facebook and she starts
and goes back and then i'm like you know
what are you doing and then we start
talking again and then she comes over a
few times
here and there and we're talking and
then we stop talking and then we have
another
this and this goes on for another it's
been going on for a month or so it's
you know it it's just not it's like
she doesn't know why she doesn't want to
be with me but she does want to be
around me and see me
and text me and and and be around you
know and you know listen
we basically have the same relationship
we had before only the difference is
i'm currently gonna try and define
another chick she doesn't like the
commitment
right but here's the thing this is a
chick that works she works and goes to
school
all day all like like it's like there's
not somebody else you know
it doesn't make sense her whole thing is
i don't see
us being together for the rest of our
lives
okay we're too different that's what she
said that's what she says we're too
different
so she's like that i don't see us having
a successful relationship because we're
too different
right i understand so what you're saying
is that like a housewife
and a guy that sells insurance they
don't have anything in common so they
can't be together
you're saying that a secretary and a guy
who's a garbage man that
live together and have a 40-year
relationship and raise three kids they
can't be together because they don't
have anything
you're telling me that only people that
both are mechanics
can survive a relationship
are you so you and your wife must have
the identical
backgrounds and careers right no you
don't that's right
right that's right that's not how it
works so the fact is it doesn't make
sense
so it's like nothing she's saying makes
sense you know she's saying i'm in love
with you
i'm attracted to you i i i love
talking to you and hanging out with you
and me you know it's like okay so
what's happening she's comfortable with
you and all that stuff is true
but she doesn't want anything long she
doesn't want to get married and have
kids with you maybe she wants to get
married and have kids but she wants
she's maybe she wants to she wants some
like somebody else some younger guy
a taller guy and i thank you what a
[ __ ] i i i
look don't think hey don't think i
haven't had that conversation i was like
i was like give me a reason tell me you
want a guy that's six foot tall
tell me you want a guy that's uh uh
that's a mechanic or you know which is
what she's going to school to be like a
mechanic
like tell me that you want a guy tell me
that i have bad breath
tell me that i'm too old for you i said
that's a toll that's a real
issue for me she's 34 and i'm 51. i'm
like tell me that that makes sense and
she's like
what are you talking about you don't
even look 51 she's like you you look
you we look like we're the same age
practically she's like i don't look 34
and you don't look 51 she was like
that's not it she's like you're amazing
you're a great
person you're great that hairline is not
a day older than 25.
it shouldn't be it cost 14 grand best
bank of america
so i need to finish one oh this one's
full
okay yeah so it doesn't make sense but
whatever it's never going to make sense
but it's not that makes sense it's not
my business
[Laughter]
whatever